how's it going everybody as I promised
you the other day I am doing another
video on more behind the scenes footage
of Avengers infinity war today in this
video we're going to see some digital
animation and editing on the battle
makanda the battle on Titan some of the
animation for Thanos and then really
cool scene some of the animation and
editing on the battle between banner and
the Hulkbuster suit and the black dwarf
or as he's called in the movie collapse
idiom before we start be sure to hit
that subscribe button to get more
behind-the-scenes footage of Avengers
infinity war and to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 there's a lot of great and
awesome footage in this video so let's
just dive right into it this first scene
is really cool because you get a glimpse
of how the editing is layered how the
whole scene comes together because it's
all animation we can see here that they
place the ground and the energy barrier
and the outriders and wakandans that are
fighting on the ground first and then
they place the explosions that are
coming from war machines rockets and
then they place war machine so
essentially they do the background first
and then they focus on the main thing in
the shot that is being filmed or
animated and edited now I do want to
point out that I am in no way an expert
on digital animation or editing at all I
am not even a novice I've never taken a
class or anything but to me this is just
super cool and I can really appreciate
the editors behind this movie this next
scene is really cool as well you got
banner in the Hulkbuster suit being
overtaken by the outriders and it's
really cool because they show you just
how simple they start with the animation
now I'm sure there's nothing simple
about it I'm sure it takes a lot of hard
work but to the eye it's kind of this
grayish outline of it and then as the
scene goes on they show you just how
detailed they get adding the color
adding the lines if you notice the
background they touch up the background
as well so it's really cool to see where
they start and where they end this next
scene isn't so much of animation editing
of the background but it's more of
Thanos face
if you're not too familiar with how this
facial animation works what they do is
they put cameras on Josh Brolin's face
who is the actor that plays stano's and
then they record all of these facial
expressions that he does while he is
acting like he's Santos and then they
animate them into what you see on screen
the first part of this next scene is
again kind of showing you the layering
of the scene the editing process and
order
that takes place when they're doing this
scene then this second part is they
actually show you the way that they
create these machines that thanasis army
has it's actually really interesting
because you can see here that they
actually engineered this machine as they
designed it it's not just the outside
layer of what we all see on the movie
screen they actually designed this in a
way that makes it look the most
realistic as it can again just another
one of those things that makes you
really appreciate what went on to make
this movie happen this next part is
great because the show Mark Ruffalo
acting like he's in the Hulkbuster suit
now
obviously he's not in a real life Iron
Man Hulkbuster suit but he has to act
like he is you can see him as he's
talking in front of the green screen
he's shift in his body acting like he's
actually getting hit you have to give it
up to these actors for just really doing
such a great job with this movie the
scene continues and they show you just
how they make the scene starting again
with the background then adding the
characters and then adding the water and
the splashes it's just it's all really
cool to see come together and again this
last scene they show you again this
piece by piece of how the scene is built
how the animation process takes place I
loved seeing all of this footage of how
everything is built the process that it
takes to make all of this come to life
on screen it's just super awesome
because Marvel movies are my favorite
movies and when you see them you're
wowed it's like wow this stuff really
looks real and we have no idea what it
takes to make it look that way and it
just always gives me a greater
appreciation of the movies that I
already love so there you have it
another behind the scenes video
breakdown and yes there are still more
to come until then be sure to subscribe
my channel and turn the notifications on
so you can be updated whenever I release
more of these videos and of course like
this video before you leave if you don't
mind as always thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]